ils ont baissé le rideau depuis vendredi
dernier non sans faire entendre leur
voix en vain les libraires contraint
désormais de s'adapter et de capter leur
clientèle via le click and collect la
vente à emporter mais vous allez le voir
tous les points de vente de livres ne
sont pas fermées hélène chapelet dans
cette maison de la presse alors qu'on
peut toujours venir acheter son journal
son programme télé où ces mots croisés
ce qui est plus surprenant c'est que les
livres eux sont toujours en accès libre
pas de cellophane de rubalise pour
empêcher leur vente et les clients
d'approché et pour cause c'est
parfaitement légal
en tant que marchand de presse et
papetiers nous sommes considérés comme
un produit indispensable à partir de ce
moment là nous avons le droit de vendre
tout ce qui se trouve dans le magasin
tout simplement parce que notre activité
principale et la presse et la papeterie
si nous étions libraires en cam activité
principale est que nous faisions la
presse nous aurions le droit d'être
ouverts pour vendre la presse mais nous
devrions neutraliser notre magasin au
niveau de la librairie
si ce commerce a donc le droit d'être
ouvert il est clair que les clients ne
se bousculent pas dans les allées
al'inverse dans cette librairie
spécialisée tourangelle le rideau lui ne
s'ouvre plus que sur demande pour
accueillir les clients qui viennent
chercher un ouvrage commandé sur
internet ou par téléphone
si le drive n'avait pas rencontré un vif
succès au premier confinement cette fois
ci le démarrage semble le meilleur
le gérant en veut pour preuve la
soixantaine de commandes en cours avec
parfois des montants à trois chiffres
là ça tombe bien parce que c'est le
début mais à mon avis on va faire quoi
ted 30 ou 40% simplement du chiffre
d'affaires donc il va manquer entre 70
et 60 %
c'est pour cela qu'on a envoyé des mails
à tous nos clients pour dire que nous
faisons des trail d'en dire on est
toujours là faut pas les oublier
ne confondez pas
sur des plateformes on existe aussi
nous on a une plateforme by the beat en
moyenne les français achètent 11 livres
par an pour un budget de 116 euros
c'est donc l'un des cadeaux préférés
sous le sapin à quelques semaines des
fêtes de fin d'année les commerçants de
proximité espèrent que leurs clients
auront le réflexe de se tourner vers eux
pour effectuer cet achat